Speaker 1: Hey, David, do you think Mitch
McConnell and Republicans will be punished
for openly obstructing everything Joe Biden
does, as Mitch McConnell has promised to do?
I wish I could tell you yes, the truth is
Mitch McConnell might be rewarded for obstructing
everything that Joe Biden tries to do.
There have been no political consequences
for Mitch McConnell and the Republicans of
2016 for blocking the Merrick Garland Supreme
Court nomination made by Barack Obama.
And not only that, many Republicans absolutely
freakin love it.
So we I mean, listen, the framing of the question
is correct in that Mitch McConnell has said
he's not going to compromise.
Mitch McConnell has said he's not Republicans
aren't going to vote for anything that Joe
Biden wants to do.
We saw it with covid stimulus.
Democrats had to go it completely alone.
It looks like it's going to be that way with
infrastructure.
These Republicans want nothing to do with
the covid, the jobs bill and on and on and
on.
Now, there's a couple of different ways that
it could go.
One is these things are popular.
Covid stimulus was popular.
Infrastructure is popular.
If Republican voters see that, hey, we got
this stuff and we like this stuff, but not
a single Republican voted for it.
They may say, let's punish these Republicans
in the fall.
Because if it were up to them, we would have
gotten nothing at the same time, others would
say, hey, you know what?
What, I still got the stuff and I don't even
have to vote for Democrats, so I'll just keep
voting for Republicans.
That's actually a rationalization we may see
among many of these Republican voters.
I think the biggest risk to Mitch McConnell
and Republicans in their obstructionism is
that a couple of Republican senators could
be Mitt Romney, could be, you know, the same
people that perennially disappoint us.
Lisa Murkowski, Susan Collins, if a couple
of them say these are simple needed things
that Joe Biden wants to do, I'm going to join
the Democrats, assuming Democrats have all
50 of theirs, including Joe Manchin and Kirsten
Sinema, and get a couple of Republicans that
could start to hurt Mitch McConnell, where
you start seeing Republicans abandoning Mitch
and saying now a lot of this stuff just makes
sense to do.
We need to do the infrastructure.
I like the jobs bill, etc.
That's the biggest risk.
But Republicans, if they remain unified, can
withhold any appearance of bipartisanship
in order to try to harm Joe Biden and Democrats.
And it could actually work.
There's this you know, bipartisanship in a
vacuum pulls well with voters.
And so while my view of bipartisanship is
the president should do things that the American
people want, if 70 percent of Americans want
covid relief, it doesn't really matter.
If you don't have enough Senate votes, you
should do covid relief.
That definition of bipartisanship is very
favorable to Joe Biden.
The counter is that there are some Americans
and again, I think that people just working
jobs and feeding their families, they don't
care about this stuff.
But there are people who do believe that bipartisanship
means you've got to have some Republicans
voting for what you're doing.
And if Republicans can remain unified, there
might be enough of those people in the Republican
Party who would say Joe Biden did it, but
he didn't do it the right way with covid cash.
It's not a factor.
I've not heard anyone say I got my fourteen
hundred bucks, but I don't want it because,
you know, Mitch McConnell didn't vote for
it.
Come on, guys, give me a break.
But with some of these other bills, that could
become a factor.
So we're going to see the question of whether
Mitch McConnell will be punished for the open.
Obstruction is a good one.
The question of whether Mitch McConnell will
be rewarded for the open obstruction is just
as good of a question.